esta vez tenemos estos grupos de
triángulos en los que vamos a volver a
pensar cuántas formas distintas tenemos
para pensar sobre este número 8 y la
primera que se me ocurre es decir que
tengo dos grupos de cuatro vamos a
dibujar con anaranjado los dos grupos de
cuatro tendremos un grupo de cuatro que
serán estos primeros y tendremos un
segundo grupo de cuatro que serán estos
segundos como podemos representar esto
en números vamos a representarlo esto
como dos veces
o lo que es lo mismo pensar que tengo 2
veces el número 4 sería un 4 una vez y
otro 4 por segunda vez tendremos 4 4 es
igual a 8 de la misma manera que podemos
decir que el 8 es el producto de dos
números enteros 2 por 4 va a ser igual a
8 cuando hablamos de multiplicación
hablamos de producto aquí tenemos dos
números enteros y el producto de estos
dos números enteros es 8 2 por 4 es
igual a 8 los invito ahora que ustedes
pausa en el vídeo e intenten distintas
maneras de representar el número 4 como
producto de dos enteros
asumiendo que pasaron del vídeo vamos a
intentarlo nosotros juntos ok
tenemos aquí el primer grupo de dos por
cuatro dos grupos de cuatro triángulos
también tenemos la posibilidad de
pensarlo como cuatro grupos de dos
tomaremos
cuatro tenemos cuatro grupos de dos
triángulos cada uno entonces lo
representaremos como 4 x
2 cuántos triángulos tiene cada uno
tiene dos triángulos cada uno y si
nosotros representamos esta
multiplicación podemos decir que tenemos
cuatro veces el número dos cuatro grupos
de dos pensaremos entonces en una 2
cuatro veces el número dos estamos bien
si nosotros hacemos la multiplicación de
dos enteros tendremos cuatro por dos y
el producto será igual a ocho
o lo podemos ver de esta manera dos más
dos son cuatro las dos son seis más dos
son ocho de cualquier manera tendremos
el total de productos que tenemos en
este conjunto que será igual a ocho otra
forma muy sencilla de representar esto
va a ser pues con grupos de 1 aquí tengo
un solo triángulo otro solo triángulo
es 45
78 digo que tengo 8 grupos de un solo
triángulo cada uno y como tal lo
representará y tendré 8 grupos de un
solo triángulo 8 x 1 será igual a 8 o
podemos representar que tengo 8 veces el
número 1 vamos a ver 1
más uno más uno más uno 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
nos faltó 1
literalmente si yo cuento esto tendré 1
1 2 1 3 1 4 5 6 7 8 que es exactamente
el producto de 8 por 1 vamos bien
finalmente tengo unos súper sencillo y
ese me gusta mucho es pensar en que
tenemos todo este grupo como uno solo
vamos entonces a considerar todo este
grupo de ocho triángulos como uno solo
y eso lo voy a representar de manera
numérica como un solo grupo por ocho
triángulos que tenemos
y esto será literalmente igual a 8
de 8 que sólo existe una vez una sola
vez del número 8 es igual a 8
y podemos contarlos cada uno de ellos
para tener nuestro total de 8 hasta
ahora nos hemos enfocado en estos
pequeños grupos de 8 pero qué sucede si
tomamos el total de estos grupos de 8
para conocer el total de triángulos que
tenemos en esta pantalla voy a borrar de
tal manera que tengamos únicamente los
triángulos de nuevo
perfecto y nos podemos enfocar entonces
en que tenemos cuatro grupos de ocho lo
ven 1 2 3 4 vamos a ponerlos en un color
cada uno de estos grupos tendremos 1
tenemos cuatro grupos de ocho triángulos
cada uno lo representaremos aquí tenemos
cuatro grupos
cada uno
y tal como hemos estado haciendo este
ejercicio antes podemos decir que
tenemos cuatro veces el número 8 vamos a
colocarlo aquí 8 más 8 más 8 más
si nosotros tenemos el producto de todo
esto 4 por 8 lo podemos saber de
nuestras tablas de multiplicar o podemos
considerar
que contaremos de 8 en 8 cada grupo 8 16
24 32
o cómo lo podemos sumar aquí 88 es igual
a 16 más 8 es igual a 24 más 8 es igual
a 32 si ustedes revisan sus tablas de
multiplicar 4 por 8 tendrá un producto
de 32
finalmente tenemos entonces conocimiento
que en total en toda esta pantalla
tenemos 32 triángulos ustedes los pueden
contar uno por uno nos vemos en otro
vídeo